On sait depuis peu de temps que des dinosaures
indiscutables qui ont un vrai squelette de
dinosaure portaient des plumes.
Mais on sait quand même depuis longtemps
qu'il y avait des animaux reptiliens avec
des plumes et il y en avait un notamment.
Dont le nom est assez connu : Archéoptéryx
qui a été découvert à la fin du XIXème
siècle.
Et pendant un peu plus d'un siècle, on ne
connaissait comme animal à la fois avec un
squelette de reptile et des plumes, on ne
connaissait que celui-là, l'Archéoptéryx.
Rien qu'avec celui-là, on imaginait déjà
des relations assez étroites entre le monde
des dinosaures et celui des oiseaux.
Et tout a changer surtout à partir des années
90 avec des découvertes en Chine.
A la fin des années 90 oui, en Chine, en
1995 des collaborations ont commencé entre
des chercheurs du monde entier notamment des
américains et des chinois.
Et on s'est rendu compte que finalement la
plupart des questions qu'on se posait sur
les relations entre les dinosaures et les
oiseaux, on avait des éléments de réponses
en Chine avec des animaux qui étaient à
la fois munis d'un squelette de reptile de
type dinosaure et parfois seulement du duvet,
parfois des petites plumes, parfois même
des grandes plumes.
Mais il ne faut pas généraliser, tous les
dinosaures n'avaient pas des plumes ? Alors,
il y avait certainement beaucoup plus de dinosaures
sans plumes qu'il n'y avait ou qu'il n'y a
de connu en tous cas de dinosaures à plumes.
Mais, ce n'est pas facile de répondre à
cette question parce que quand on fait des
fouilles paléontologique, on cherche des
ossements essentiellement.
Et on est pas forcément capable quand on
dégage des ossements de dinosaures d'une
roche de savoir si avec ces ossements, il
y avait des plumes d'associées.
Il faut des conditions de fossilisations très
particulières avec le squelette préservé
sur une surface plane avec les empreintes
des plumes autour du corps pour être sûr
qu'avec une espèce de dinosaure on peut associer
des plumes.
Dans beaucoup de cas finalement, on connaît
des squelettes de dinosaure dont on sera peut-être
jamais capable de dire si oui ou non ils avaient
des plumes.
Mais chez les oiseaux qui volaient déjà
il y a plus de 66 millions d'années quand
les dinosaures étaient encore là, chez ces
oiseaux il y avait déjà des plumes efficaces pour le vol.
Oui, il y avaient des
oiseaux qui volaient parfaitement bien
on va dire il y a a peu près 140 millions d'années
c'est sûr. Peut-être même avant, avant
la fin du Jurassique il y a 150 millions d'années.
Il y avaient des animaux volants à plumes
qu'on pourrait appeler des oiseaux.